[Musique]
intéressant avec son histoire arish de
logis seigneurial le château de
beaugency dans le loiret vient d'être
investi par un couple de jeunes qui ont
métamorphosé en un centre d'art
numérique c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi ma
tête se trouve à l'intérieur de ce
qu'ils appellent le yart à 7
ça fait beaucoup de moi quand même vous
l'avez compris ils ont créé un concept
original qui offre à ce lieu d'exception
mais moi j'arrive pas savoir où il
aurait connu
bonjour cabinet y voit kamini bienvenue
hsbc
[Musique]
le château de beaugency bonjour anne
sophie bonjour jérémy au cabinet alors
vous êtes un peu des chevaliers des
temps modernes parce que ici à la base
c'est quand même un château où il y
avait des chevaliers mais vous vous êtes
les chevaliers des temps modernes l'art
numérique en place dans ce patrimoine
exceptionnel oui en effet on a remplacé
les épées par les ordinateurs et puis on
propose ici nouvelle lecture du château
à travers l'art numérique alors il ya
deux aspects à l'aspect architecture là
c'est plus anne sophie et l'art
numérique c'est plus jérémy c'est bien
ça t'a fait injustement on parle de
pratiques artistiques parce que à la
base tous les deux vous êtes architecte
comment on passe de l'architecturé à
l'art numérique bah ça s'est fait de
jouer avec ma rencontre avec le cinéma
donc l'image est rentré par j'irai les
études de cinéma que j'ai menées en
parallèle avec le l'architecturé le
maqâm diplôme architecture avocat récusé
de cinéma dentiste j'ai un problème là
là dans la comptable a fais tout
moi j'ai hâte de découvrir tout ce qui
se cache à l'intérieur de cette nouvelle
formule du château de beaugency on y va
enfin tout allait partir
donc là on arrive la première oeuvre
première expo pour moi le s'appelle
red star ac magnifique moi j'aime ça
m'inspire
or
on sourit jérémy rabot de beaugency vie
puis semaine passionnante 3d et on a
aussi l'impression d'être avec mylène
farmer
[Musique]
allez reprendre la ville adorée
il épouse camille
sa mort
ça m'a inspiré quand même votre vos
espoirs sait c'est très inspirant
reprend l'artiste nous sommes donc dans
les jardins du château de beaugency il
était dans quel état quand vous êtes
arrivé ici alors c'est un jardin qui
avait besoin d'être rafraîchis
essentiellement saint germain qui a été
construit il ya une vingtaine d'années
et qui est une inspiration jardin
renaissance qu'a voulu gens dans
l'hérault ville qui est un des
propriétaires du château il ya même des
partenariats avec thomas puisque et
c'est ça oui on a un partenariat qui lie
thomas pesquet et notamment lâché en
train de travailler au sein du château
sur le projet avec du coup les visuels
de l' agence spatiale européenne et les
vues de l'espace jusque où vous allez on
centre val de loire vous êtes fous en
fait vous êtes fous vous êtes fous nous
devons dans l'espace chef ou s'ils sont
si tu as raison il est un
peu fou hein